so what was going through your mind when
you turned around because i didn't
really get to talk to you much after
that what was going through your mind
when you turned around during your
performance and you were like wait what
yeah i couldn't believe it it takes a
while
to to actually realize that you're not
watching him behind the screen
because i've watched him for years since
i was a child
yeah so to now be like wait this isn't
behind any kind of screen or anything
he's actually here
yeah it took me a while so even when i
went up to him i'm like
what what i my favorite part was
i love like because not everybody you
meet in the industry
is super kind always um and so i love
that you
loved him since you're a kid and then
you get to meet him and he's actually a
really good and kind dude that was my
favorite part personally and like
your excitement like your level of joy
that shot from your skin was amazing and
so infectious
it was awesome um so watching the clip
back on a scale of one to ten
what would you rate john's dance moves
as just saying
ah is he going to watch this
that answer
answer so you really mean like a four
[Laughter]
i mean for me the fact that he wear i
think he's aware
he's not that bad he's not that bad i'll
give him a six you give me
okay that's nice that's kind very pc of
[Music]
you